wir sollen einen film über die
legalisierung von cannabis tore ideen ja
klar wir brauchen experten wir brauchen
den experten jochen karl lauterbach karl
lauterbach und stellt sie das vor der
mann ist jetzt gesundheitsminister der
hat zu tun das ist nicht wie früher wo
wir einmal karl aut aber prüfen und zack
steht
[Musik]
ja herr lauterbach wir müssen direkt mit
einer enttäuschung starten wir wollen
heute wieder über corona noch über
marcus lanz reden und das wird schwer
dann reden für mich aber das ist okay
ist okay das ist also wir können sehr
präsentes thema gibt da wollen wir doch
mal sehen herzlich willkommen zu wer
braucht denn so was und die wichtigste
frage zuerst haben sie schon einmal
geraucht und was braucht eigentlich
wolfgang kubicki und wolfgang kubicki
geraucht das weiß ich nicht es muss auf
jeden fall sehr stark sein und ein guter
arzt probiert alles aus also seine
patienten beraten zu können von daher
hat also habe ich auch schon konsumiert
und wie war es angenehm muss ich sagen
also ich bin bringt in angenehmer
erinnerung aber wie gesagt also das war
nur
man will den menschen helfen aber sie
waren ja am anfang gegen eine
legalisierung lasst uns richtig aber das
also hat sich verändert in den letzten
jahren jetzt sind die sicherheitsaspekte
die eine legalisierung mitbringt die
sind so überwiegend also ich meine
meinung geändert habe und ich bin für
die legalisierung ich dachte sie wären
jetzt dafür weil sich eine koalition mit
der fdp nur bekiffter tragen lässt die
war damals noch nicht absehbar als ich
meine meinung geändert habe aber
tatsächlich also die fdp hilft hier und
das ganze voranzubringen ich werde in
regelmäßigen abständen auf den flur und
von den kollegen nichts sag mal was ich
dich noch fragen wollte wann kommt denn
der kanal ist wir wollen jetzt mal
zunächst über die gesundheitlichen
aspekte sprechen
es gibt ja auch nebenwirkungen das kann
man ja nicht unterschätzen zum beispiel
die gefahr dass man vom kiffen so träge
und müde wird die olaf scholz also ich
bin sicher dass also urlaub der die
dynamik klaren person ist hier ein gutes
beispiel wäre da würde mir andere leute
einfallen aber es ist tatsächlich
kontinuierlicher konsum kann
so lethargisch machen und das gehört zu
den neben willkommen und olaf scholz ist
es jemand der mal
muss früher stattgefunden habe aber
braucht es heute nicht also
es ist ja ist einfach dynamisch also
konzentriert eine freude also mit ihm
zusammenzuarbeiten alles gut er sie sind
immer noch die ironie minister auf jeden
fall neuland und das alles hier etwa
hatten bars damit wir wollen nicht nur
reden habe ich wollte es selber auch mal
probieren einen einen selbstversuch und
ich als väterlicher freund macht mir ein
bisschen sorgen weil es ja bei
jugendlichen so ist es kann tatsächlich
zu psychosen kommen weil das gehirn noch
nicht richtig ausgebildet ist ja es wird
er von der neuen regelung als
minderjähriger wäre er noch nicht
geschützt und von daher wäre das jetzt
auch an versucht er nicht wirklich also
gezeigt werden dass das gar nicht das
darf nicht aufs behandelt kann ich da
nicht unter der hand über sie irgendwie
anders kommen da kann ich nichts machen
also bei minderjährigen sei unter
18-jährigen wie ihnen kann ich meine
schützende hand nicht darüber halten
finden sie das gut dass jetzt auch
selber mal ausprobieren würden sie einem
erwachsenen also haben wir ihnen ja aber
es reicht jetzt alle jährigen so kann
man das nicht riskieren hier sprechen
die gleiche sprache wir wollen jetzt
auch noch mal über die umsetzung
sprechen es gibt ja auch viele
rechtliche hürden errichtet am ende
könnten sie ja an eu-recht scheitern das
heißt sie könnten der an die scheuer der
ampel werden das stimmt dass sender tat
hier ein risiko die eu rechtlichen
belange so gehen in die richtung dürfen
wir das überhaupt ist gefährlich war
tatsächlich die seerechtskonvention sind
zu beachten daher also muss völkerrecht
und eu recht müssen beachtet werden und
daran arbeiten wir wenn sie das zeug
legalisieren müssten sie eine uno
konvention und das schengen abkommen
brechen und dann ist natürlich die frage
was ist ihr neuer spitzname carlos
escobar würden wir anbieten wir kommen
da umher ich glaube dass wir das
schaffen können ohne das recht zu
brechen ich würde aber einräumen dass es
riskant aber keiner kann uns sagen die
man das eu recht umgehen will es gibt
diverse
also möglichkeiten im haus haben wir an
der rechtsabteilung die ihr brot
gegessen hat und die tragen schon im
kern vor dass unsere möglichkeiten wären
es ist mehr als ein dann kann man auf
die schieben nein also wir brauchen
nichts zu schieben das wird kommen das
wird ja aber wenn die wenn die ampel rot
ist und ich beim auto drüber fahrer
hilft mir auch nichts zu sagen ich habe
aber eine gute rechtsabteilung die
rechtsabteilung also löst das hier wir
haben internationale beratung kann sie
beruhigen es wird zum schluss kommen ich
hoffe dass mit anderen worten unser
motto ist wir packen das
[Musik]
guck mal fabian das ist einer von diesen
coffeeshops das wäre doch eine gute idee
eigentlich will seinen beitrag wenn wir
mal in so ein shop gehen und auch mal so
fabian habe ja
so lutz genug gelagert ich will jetzt
endlich einen durchziehen ja ja ok aber
nur unter ärztlicher aufsicht keine
sorge ich habe professor doktor müller
wahlen eingeladen sie ist eine der
führenden ärzten zum thema cannabis als
medizin weltweit in deutschland ist
cannabis eben problematisch noch alkohol
es habe gar kein problem also man kriegt
in deutschland rund um die uhr immer
alkohol
wie sehen sie denn das so im vergleich
zu cannabis eigentlich das ist
schizophren also ich glaube das ist
wirklich eine tradition die hier haben
aber die ist durch nichts
wissenschaftlich begründet das ist ja so
ein stückchen historisch zu sehen und
dahinter steht nicht etwa wissen und
verstand sondern das hat wirtschaftliche
gründe gehabt dass man den alkohol
befördert und cannabis verhindert habe
ich denke jede gesellschaft muss für
sich überlegen wie sie mit drogen umgeht
und da kann man sagen wir machen das
liberale oder weniger liberal aber
sollte ihn sich eine logik haben und das
fehlt momentan gibt es auch eine gefahr
abhängig zu werden von cannabis gibt es
alle drogen können abhängig machen das
ist ja sozusagen die definitionen was
eine droge ausmacht und man weiß ist
völlig unstrittig dass cannabis ein
geringeres abhängigkeits risiko hat als
zb an geholt wenn jetzt die wirkung ein
bisschen stärker ist als beabsichtigt
kann man da aktiv gegen wirken also die
wirkung kann sehr unterschiedlich
ausfallen gerade bei menschen die das
jetzt noch nie eingenommen haben kann
ist ein sie gar nichts merken das kann
auch daran liegen dass sie eine zu
geringe menge einnehmen und es gibt eine
ganz seltene interessante
nebenwirkung das nennt sich cannabis
syndrom das heißt also man kriegt ein
unstillbares erbrechen haben aber nur
ganz wenig menschen zwar schon sehr
lustig muss von sa gefahr werden wenn
das bei dir auftreten still bares
ja weil man sich sehr stark erbricht das
liegt wahrscheinlich an der genetischen
veranlagung
interessanterweise kriegt man das zum
stoppen indem man sich in der warme
badewanne aber er bricht mir dabei sind
die man da hört es dann auf ist aber
extrem selten ich habe es noch nie
gesehen und glaube auch deswegen nicht
sagen wir vorsichtshalber das wasser
schon mal einen lassen ich glaube nicht
herkommen wir staates oder sterbens
nicht lange herumreden jetzt gehen sie
sind dabei und begleitet und ich pass
medizinisch dass es nicht passt auf
alles klar ok los geht's
die folgenden bilder enthalten sensible
inhalte und können für manche zdf
betrachter verstörend sollen sich bitte
nicht nachmachen
[Musik]
wie
heißt du
hast du sehr gut gemacht fabian
[Musik]
ja aber du siehst anders aus als sonst
zur glasige augen
merkt doch jetzt heftig und was das ja
so dass halt alles etwas unwirklicher
dann erhöhten herzschlag
also bin nicht so viel sie bringen es ja
das was wir im medizinischen bereich
gerade alles nicht wollen also die
effekte die jetzt hier auftreten und
dann machen wir es ja ganz anders nicht
auf einmal ganz viel und hoffentlich
merke ich dann irgendwas wie bei
medikamenten das langsam auf dosiert
wird man sich daran gewöhnt und im
idealfall schafft man es dass solche
gefühle von benommenheit schwindel
müdigkeit gar nicht auftreten unserer
pausieren pausieren
du bist mein geschmack gekommen ich will
es jetzt wichtig
so richtig gut drauf ist es noch nicht
aber für den fall hatte ich natürlich
was vorbereitet bist du denn jetzt in
der stimmung für meine wortspiele
aber macht sie ja nicht schwöre ich
lache aber keinem aber sie können gern
machen wenn sie ist lustig finden
ich sag ja immer kein gras das kommt mir
nicht in die tüte
sie machen aber
halten weil ich
jetzt kannst du marie
marie
will muss ich wieder da ja ganz lustig
wie sie
anschluss frage kennst du hanna marie
hoch
bis frage wie heißt der keeper weiß
daraus
kann
es geht alles wieder weg
warum
wie geht's dir denn mir geht es schlecht
nicht ins programm nehmen ich will dass
es vorbeigehe das habe ich auch mal das
merke ich finde es amüsant
aber bei mir sind jetzt so ein karussell
geschwinde schwang das nerven bis hinter
sich wir möchten uns jetzt verabschieden
von der sendung und auch von paul müller
war also sehr vielen dank für die
medizinische begleitung
gerne
[Musik]
und was soll das war fabian das ist tik
tok dass es youtube lutz und die leute
müssen hier nur abonnieren oder auf ein
anderes video klicken und das wird alles
neben mir eingeblendet
wie youtube der junge ist so 2000
[Musik]